AS COWBOYS, WE SAW A LITTLE
JERRY JONES AT THE TOP
TALKING ABOUT BEING
VACCINATED. HERE IS JERRY
JONES TALKING ABOUT THE
SELECTION, THE COWBOYS WORKED
HARD TO EARN LAST YEAR. 10TH
OVERALL, WHAT ARE THEY GOING
TO DO? HERE'S JERRY. I THINK
TODAY. WE'VE GOT A GOOD
CHANCE TO HAVE A TOP
DEFENSIVE PLAYER. THE TOP
ONE OF THE TOP BE THERE AT
10:00. I THINK THE REAL
DON'T BE, DON'T BE STUPID
OVER YOUR NEEDS.
JUST JUST TALK, DON'T BE
RIDICULOUS.
THAT'S THAT'S SOME SAGE
ADVICE. DON'T BE STUPID OVER
YOUR NEEDS. YEAH, THE TEAMS
WILL SAY BEST AVAILABLE BEST
AVAILABLE. WE'RE TAKING THE
BEST AVAILABLE. YOUR BEST.
AVAILABLE ASSESSMENT IS
ALWAYS DRIVEN BY YOUR NEEDS
AND THE COWBOYS HAVE CLEAR
NEEDS ON DEFENSE. BUT HEY
CHRIS. THEY ALSO NEED TO
START THINKING ABOUT
REFILLING SOME OF THOSE SPOTS
ON THE OFFENSE. SURE, I CAN.
THAT WALL IS CRUMBLING, I
MEAN, IT IS BUT, YOU KNOW,
THERE'S STILL A LOT OF MONEY
AND ASSETS POURED INTO THAT
WALL. AND I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S TIME TO LIKE
THE START WASTING OR I DON'T
WANT TO SAY WASTE, BUT GOING
TO THE 10TH, PICK OF THE
DRAFT TO REPLENISH THE OLD
LINE. I DON'T THINK IT'S THAT
TIME YET. YEAH THEY GOT TO
START THINKING ABOUT
RETOOLING, IT MAKING A
YOUNGER AND THEY CAN DO THAT
AND SOME OF THE LATER ROUNDS
IN THE DRAFT, BUT I MEAN,
NEED A DIFFERENCE MAKER TO,
YOU KNOW, FOR WHAT JERRY
SAYING? YEAH, THEY NEED THEY
NEED THE BEST DEFENSIVE
PLAYER IN THE DRAFT, WHOEVER
THEY SEE FIT TO BE THAT GUY,
YOU KNOW, THERE ARE TEAM. I
DO SIT THERE AND LOOK AT A
NUMBER 10. LISTEN? YEAH, I
I'M MOCKED THEM TO, YOU KNOW,
PATCH
ERIC CERTEYN, RIGHT? WE
CERTAINLY COULD SEE THAT THE
BEST DEFENSIVE PLAYER IN THE
DRAFT IS JALEN PHILLIPS IS
THE DEFENSIVE END FROM MIAMI.
WILL THEY TAKE HIM YOU KNOW
WITH THE CONCUSSION HISTORY
AND ALL THAT? I MEAN HE'S A
COWBOY'S TYPE OF GUY YOU KNOW,
BIG FREAKY, YOU KNOW,
BIG FREAKY, YOU KNOW
SUPERSTUD KIND OF HUMAN
BEING THAT WOULD MAKE SENSE
BUT I DON'T KNOW THERE'S
RISK THERE AND THAT'S THAT'S
GOING TO BE, YOU KNOW,
SOMETHING TO WATCH FOR WITH
THAT TEN PICK ON THURSDAY
NIGHT. WE'LL TALK ABOUT THE
MOCK DRAFT IN LESS THAN AN
SARTAIN IS GONE WHEN THE
COWBOYS PICK UNDER THAT
FORMULATION. SO SPOILER ALERT,
IT MAY NOT BE A DEFENSIVE
PLAYER AT ALL FOR THE DALLAS
COWBOYS BUT WE SHALL SEE AS
WE WILL WITH ALL THE OTHER
PICS. OBVIOUSLY, HERE'S MORE
FROM JERRY JONES. GO AHEAD,
GO AHEAD. I WAS GOING TO SAY,
YOU KNOW, YOU GOT TO BALANCE,
YOU KNOW, TO, TO THE THE
SUPPLIER OF AVAILABLE OR
NEEDS OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
TO, YOU KNOW, AT SOME POINT
THOUGH, THERE HAS TO BE A
SPOT WHERE, OKAY, HEY, THIS
IS THE BEST PLAYER AVAILABLE,
BUT WE'RE PLENTIFUL AT THIS
POSITION, RIGHT? AND THEN IT
MAKES NO SENSE, LIKE I WOULD
USE, HEY, I'LL USE THE GREEN
BAY PACKERS, IS THAT EXAMPLE,
THEY SIGNED PRESTON SMITH
AND ZA'DARIUS SMITH AND FREE
AGENCY A FEW YEARS AGO THEN
THEY HAD A TOP TEN PICK AND
THEY DRAFTED ROCHON GARY WHO
PLAYS THE SAME POSITION? THE
AND NOW, HE'S REALLY DOESN'T
HAVE A ROLE ON THE FOOTBALL
TEAM. SO THAT'S WHERE YOU CAN
ALWAYS JUST GO. WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE BEST PLAYER AVAILABLE.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE SOME
BALANCE ABOUT WHAT'S ON YOUR
ROSTER AND YOUR TEAM, YOU
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT GUY
CAN TRULY CAPITALIZE ON
HELPING YOUR TEAM AND BE THE
BEST HE CAN BE TOO. I THINK
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT AND
TO THE EXTENT THAT THESE
TEAMS GET SO BLINDLY TIED TO
THEIR BOARDS THAT THEY THEY
MUST TAKE THAT NEXT NAME,
THAT POPS UP, NO MATTER WHAT
POSITION. HE PLAYS YOU AREN'T
CRAFTING YOUR BOARD WITH
NO MIND. AND I JUST THINK YOU
HAVE TO CRAFT YOUR BOARD WITH
YOUR NEEDS IN MIND. THIS IS
YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO FILL
THOSE NEEDS. YOU'VE ALREADY
HAD FREE AGENCY, WHATEVER
NEEDS YOU HAVE LEFT UNLESS
YOU'RE GOING TO WORK A TRADE
OR SOMEBODY'S GOING TO GET
UNEXPECTEDLY CUT, AND THEY'RE
GOING TO FALL INTO YOUR LAPS
OR GOING TO GET SOME
UNDRAFTED FREE AGENT OR SOME
GUY WHO JUST HAPPENS TO BE
HANGING AROUND AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN HE WORKS OUT. THIS IS
YOUR CHANCE TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS THAT YOU HAVE NOW WON
NEED COWBOYS. DON'T HAVE IS
PAST CATCHER, BUT THERE'S
INFATUATION IT WITH FLORIDA
TIGHT END KAUP. ITS FIRST OF
ALL, JOIN THE CLUB. YES,
SECOND OF ALL JERRY SPOKE
YESTERDAY ABOUT THE
SUPPOSED COW PITS
INFATUATION. HERE'S THE
QUESTION AND THEN JERRY'S
ANSWER.
COME OUT. SAY YOU WERE
INFATUATED WITH A GUY LIKE
PITS. IS THAT LEGITIMATE? OR
DO YOU JUST LIKE JENNA? HOW
NOT LEGITIMATE? BUT WHEN I
SAY IT, I AM ANYBODY IN THIS
DRAFT IS IMPRESSIVE. OKAY.
PROBABLY AN EXAGGERATION IS
FASCINATED. I MAY HAVE USED
THE WORD MYSELF, BUT THE
POINT IS THAT IT'S A
DISTORTION FOR THIS DRAFT AND
WHERE WE ARE. THERE IT
IMPLIES SOMETHING THAT'S JUST
NOT CASE, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GO IN THERE AND SPEND
SPEND INORDINATE THAT A
COLLATERAL OR VALUE TO
MANEUVER UP THERE, SO THAT WE
OR PITS AT THE CASE MAY BE.
YOU HEAR STEPHEN JONES?
OF LET OUT ON AUDIBLE
DIALOGUE. YOU GOD I DID NOT.
UH HUH KILL THE MIGHT LIKE
DON'T ASK THIS GUY ABOUT HIM
AND LIKE WEIRD YEAH WHEN HE
STARTED INTO THAT
EXPLANATION BUT HEY I THINK
JERRY DID A GOOD JOB OF NOT
TIPPING THEIR HAND AND IT
AIN'T GONNA MATTER UNLESS
THEY'RE MOVING UP TO 4.
IT'S ALL ACADEMIC. KYLE PITS
IS MOST LIKELY NOT GOING TO
BE LINGERING ON THE BOARD.
RIGHT, HOW BOYS PICK AT
NUMBER TEN OR SEVEN EIGHT,
NINE RANGE WHERE THEY WOULD
TRADE UP A FEW SPOTS AND THEY
DON'T NEED THEY JUST DON'T
NEED HIM AND THIS IS WHERE WE
GET INTO BEST AVAILABLE
VERSUS NEED. YOU'VE GOT FAR
GREATER REQUIREMENTS THAT YOU
NEED TO BETRAY TO BE A
COMPETITIVE FOOTBALL TEAM IN
2021. YEAH, THAT'S RIGHT.
AND I MEAN, YOU KNOW, AGAIN A
TEAM
THIS AS MANY HOLES AS THEY
HAVE RIGHT NOW ESPECIALLY ON
THE DEFENSIVE SIDE. I MEAN,
ARE WE REALLY GOING TO TRADE
AWAY PICKS TO MOVE UP TO
LIKE LIKE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
FIRST OFF? I MEAN YOU'RE
REALLY REALISTICALLY HAVE TO
MOVE UP TO 4 BECAUSE, YOU
KNOW, YOU GOT IT, YOU GOT TO
ENSURE, YOU KNOW, FOUR OR
FIVE OR SIX PITS. A GOOD
CHANCE IS GOING TO ONE OF
THOSE THREE TEAMS RIGHT THERE.
I MEAN I'D BE SHOCKED IF HE
GOT OUT OF THAT LITTLE RUN OF
TEAMS THERE BETWEEN, YOU KNOW,
FALCONS THE DOLPHINS. AND OF
COURSE THE CINCINNATI BENGALS
WHO WERE SANDWICHED IN THE
MIDDLE.
THEY'RE SO YEAH, I EXPECT THE
THE WHERE THEY ARE AND, YOU
TAKE THE BEST DEFENSIVE
PLAYER AVAILABLE, I THINK
THAT'S MORE OF THE BEST WAY
TO SAY IT. BEST DEFENSIVE
PLAYER AVAILABLE. THAT'S A
SECONDARY GUY OR A DIFFERENCE
MAKER UP FRONT AND THERE'S NO
DEFENSIVE TACKLE THAT'S WORTH
THE NUMBER TEN, PICK OF THE
DRAFT. SO THEN IT REALLY GETS
INTO A NUMBERED FEW, YOU
TO GET INTO PATRICK SARTAIN
JC HORN WITH THE SOUTH
CAROLINA, GAMECOCKS RIGHT?
OF THE LIST AND THEY FIT THAT
SEATTLE SCHEME, AND MAKE
SENSE FOR THEM TO TAKE THEM
AND THEN YOU GO INTO. OKAY.
WHAT'S THE NEXT THING? EDGE
RUSHER. AND THAT'S IT'S A
SHORT LIST OF PEOPLE, TO ITS
JALEN PHILLIPS, WHO HAD
EARLIER, QUIT EPA JASON AWAY.
YOU KNOW, MAYBE FROM PENN
STATE, BUT I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY LOOKS AT HIM AS BEING
THE TOP TEN PICK. SO IT'S
REALLY FOUR GUYS. IN MY MIND
IT'S THE TWO CORNERS, QUIT
EPA AND JALEN PHILLIPS. I
THINK THAT'S THEIR OPTIONS
RIGHT THERE AND I'LL BE
INTERESTED TO SEE WHICH ONE
THEY GO WITH. LET ME ASK
AND PRESS THE GRAPHIC THAT WE
JUST HAD UP WITH THE COWBOYS.
I HAVE TO MAKE ONE
OBSERVATION THAT PHOTO OF
MIKE MCCARTHY HAD TO BE FROM
THE DAY HE WAS INTRODUCED AS
THE HEAD COACH OF THE TEAM.
RIGHT? BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
THE LAST TIME HE'S BEEN HAPPY.
I REALLY DO. I MEMORIZED
SERIOUSLY. AM I WRONG? WAS
THAT WRONG? OKAY, YOU'RE NOT
WRONG. IT'S BEEN A IT'S BEEN
A BUMPY ROAD FOR MIKE
MCCARTHY TO THIS POINT.
THAT THE HONEYMOON YEAR DID
NOT GO THE WAY IT WAS
SUPPOSED TO THERE. SO YEAH,
THEY GOT A LOT OF WORK IN
FRONT OF THEM AND AS
INTRIGUING AS A KYLE PIZZAS
AND ALL THAT. NO I THINK
THAT'S KIND OF CRAZY TALK. I
THINK JERRY PUT IT RIGHT? HE
WAS JUST WAXING, POETIC LIE
ABOUT A GUY THAT HEY QUITE
HONESTLY I'VE NEVER SEEN A
TIGHT END LIKE LIKE KYLE PITS
IS ESPECIALLY SINCE I'VE
BEEN IN THIS SIDE OF THE
BUSINESS WHERE I WATCHED TAPE
AND EVALUATE GUYS COMING OUT
IN THE DRAFT AND ALL THAT
HE'S SPECIAL. BUT YEAH, THE
COWBOYS DON'T ENNETYED O TF HEF